smedley butler iii says pat what if hype
what if hyperinflation is their goal
what if it is their final phase what if
the people have to be brought to their
knees before they'll accept the world
digital id system hegelian dialectic
listen a lot of people
agree with you and believe what you're
saying and we know what hegelian
dialectic is and it's a strategy that's
worked effectively by
big governments for a long long time so
i'm not weighing that out i'm not
telling you there's not a group of
people that are not planning to do that
at the top i'm just telling you i don't
think it's everybody i think there are
certain people that want to do the right
thing i think there's certain people
that think
uh uh uh are not coming from that
standpoint but i do believe
the people that are the puppet masters
behind closed doors have some things
like that in mind because they're driven
by control they love control and they
hate rich people they hate anybody that
got rich under this system because they
wanted to be
you know taken away from them because
they can't stand the fact that these
guys independently not needing the
government ended up being successful
i've said this before i'll say it again
a parent when they lose
the the the need of their kids saying if
you don't do this i'm not gonna buy that
when the kid eventually gets to a point
i says mom i don't give a [ __ ] i buy it
myself that control is gone and a mom
and a dad is like wait a minute i feel
like i just lost my child i feel like i
just lost my child you didn't lose your
child he became independent these
politicians are thinking they're still
the mother the nanny state to say you
need us you need us and the people like
i don't need you i can independently
take care of myself just leave me alone
let's co-exist and enjoy these every
once in a while family gatherings that
we have every four years when we got to
vote for the next president but outside
of that leave me alone well and the
people that are pushing these policies
are phenomenally wealthy within
themselves pelosi's worth what 350
million
i mean she's worth a ton of money joe
biden is working one of the best stock
pickers of all time oh yeah great her
husband
one of the best stock pickers of all
time
when she has time it's very she's she's
a legendary you got to budget your time
like elon musk so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]